ces is in full swing and you may be
wondering which gadgets are trending on
the show floor well of course we know an
expert who can point them out to us
joining us this morning is our friend dr
frank vigiano good morning dr frank and
so good to see you is there a trend uh
at ces this year
there is a trend the trends are all over
the different products that we'll cover
this morning i think one of the biggest
you know televisions is always tv has
always been a major thing at cbs and lg
introduced oled about 10 years ago and
they're actually revamping that whole
entire line and some of the things
they're doing they're amazing it's
spectacular picture quality
by any yardstick you know it is the best
tv currently on the market what's
interesting they've upgraded their
technology and features to get a more
perfect picture and quality viewing from
any environment and what you're going to
look at on the video is 97 inch oled tv
can you imagine that sharing 97 inches
wow unbelievable that is huge
that is it is huge so basic yeah so it's
rivaling two-piece projection now so
instead of putting projector hanging
from the ceiling in the screen people
are looking at a 97-inch tv and saying
why not and so it's you know deeper
blacks it has the next generation ai
processor etc and this is called the
gallery level design which has a razor
thin bezel and our video shows that as
well but it's really a very unique
product it's like being in the movie
theater but you're at home yep it's been
really good and also won the ces
innovation award as well oh wow and you
said that's like an oscar for ces right
yes anytime you win that award and i've
been a judge for them for many many
years it's like an oscar in our business
so if someone is awarded the ces
innovation award that means that it's
earned you know from a lot of judges we
a lot of people look at it but for that
perspective it's unique different and
it's worthy of an award
well what about home tech and and safety
i'm sure they're always coming out with
more of that yes yes absolutely and kita
has introduced basically a smoke and co
alarm so you've got two in one and they
have a lot of smart features so the
benefit is it allows you to take control
of a safer home with smart capabilities
and whole home activations now it can
receive remote notifications on your
phone with the app and you can double
that detection as it gets said before
with smoke and co it has a 10 year
battery life which is wonderful so no
chirping anymore sherry you basically
that battery lasts 10 years and it's
guaranteed and the app is available on
both the apple and google stores it's
voice control so it's compatible with
google assistant and amazon alexa it
uses voice commands to check the alarm
the status and the connection fully
integrated solution that also allow you
to to connect to existing
interconnected hardwire alarms only
89.97 it will be available exclusively
at home depot well i love that anything
that you can connect to an app and is
voice activated but i'd buy it for the
10-year battery life dr frank i'm not
going to lie i'm not lying i love it
okay what else do you have for us all
right so now we were talking about
storage and a lot of people are really
kind of freaked about the cloud and i
get a lot of questions from a lot of my
viewers like dr frank i really don't
like putting my things up there i don't
know where it's going who else can see
it so owc has introduced something
called the envoy pro fx so it's advanced
storage technology that you basically
have you know your own you keep it and
it'll plug and play with yesterday today
and tomorrow's macs or pcs or ipad pros
or chromebooks or whatever but it
supports maximum performance and it
basically uses both it will compatible
with both thunderbolt and usb interface
it's built like a tank you can drop it
dust proof waterproof certified transfer
speeds at 2800 megabytes per second
available up to two terabytes of storage
sherry which is enormous and it starts
at 219 available from maxsails.com
that's fantastic i never have enough
storage for anything it's mostly
pictures but for all of the stuff i can
never find enough storage i like that
i'm getting that absolutely and it's
very affordable oh that's wonderful it
is affordable what about for kids
anything for kids or ces yeah this is
important and tuki they won the
innovation award for 2022 great product
very unique because it has no screen and
you know what we want to do is get the
kids away from the screen and get
interaction so that they basically grow
and develop etc so it's powered by toy
touch technology it uses figurines and
tokens to stream playlists and wi-fi has
wi-fi and bluetooth connectivity uh just
received as i said the innovation award
is the first speaker for kids with no
screen
so it empowers children to develop
creativity and independence appearance
can set the volume limits it has an
eight hour battery and free shipping and
you can get it at jukey
dot rocks 112.99
great product wonderful technology for
education oh that sounds great i love
the tokens and the figurines that's
really cool
very fun
interactive for the kids too without the
screen love that absolutely wow well
thank you dr frank and i know you were
handicapped with all the flying problems
and everything going on but please stay
healthy get out there don't worry yes
stay healthy stay well and thanks for
showing us all the cool stuff at ces
oh glad thanks for having me on it's
always a pleasure to be with you guys
and i'll be seeing you in person soon
you bet happy new year